Hello, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert
Krulwich, Radiolab. Today's topic,
parasites, where we have already
learned that parasites can be good.
Sometimes Harris' fades
can of course be very bad.
That also parasites can affect
human behavior. Making this,
some of us a little lethargic
or solving our allergies. Yeah.
Here's the question to consider though.
Can they not just affect our behavior?
Can they control our behavior and
different question in time? Yeah.
And you know, we were, we were
thinking about this question, you know,
in the abstract doing some research,
but then things got kind of real when
our producer Ellen Horn called in late to
work one day.
Hey Lulu, it's Alan. I just
got home from the, that um,
I've been waiting on chest x
rays, um, blood work from my cat.
She managed staff to meet with
them. This is my cat, my big,
lovely affectionate kitty. She's like
the sweetest cat you will ever meet.
I've met Louis. He's a very sweet cat.
He's a darling. But Moose has, uh,
digestion problems.
And this one day I had to take her to
the vet and as I was putting her into the
kitty carrier,
she managed the scratch me with her
bat claws and like a bloody wound on my
hand. Her back claws are
like totally pooped covered.
So I'm kind of worried I
have six months pregnant.
The very first thing that they tell you
when you get pregnant is stay away from
cat poop. So after it happened, I called
my with my CSC. Are you ready for me?
Yeah. She told me to rush right down
to her office to bled pretty profusely.
H did. Wait a second. Why? What's
so scary about cat poop? Well,
it turns out that cat poop can have in
it this tiny parasite called Toxoplasma
Gondii. Well what is the threat to
the baby if it gets to the baby?
It can cause miscarriage.
It can cause stillbirth and it can
also cause seizures, blindness.
So you're, you're, you're
freaking out at this point. Yeah,
I'm kind of freaking out the,
this cranium small head. Ah.
My midwife said there's probably nothing
to worry about. So just took my blood.
That's probably the better arm.
Can you say question yet?
And she sent me home.
The turnaround time for the test is
between two and three days. Okay. Okay.
So I'm looking, um, the Antoinette, yeah.
At home I proceed to get
myself even more freaked out.
A bunch of things about toxoplasma.
One of the things that I found was
this lecture by Robert Sapolsky.
Tell me an example I'm talking about here.
He's a neuroscientist who
we've had on the show.
It has to do with a
parasite called Toxoplasma.
And um, I just decided that
I was going to call them up.
Hello and ask a few questions.
Okay. So what's the deal with Toxo?
And he proceeded to tell me one of the
most amazing zinc feats of mind control,
but I'd ever heard one.
What'd he tell you? Well,
the first thing he me is that toxo
doesn't actually want to be in me. Yes.
It really has wandered off into the
wrong county. If it winds up in a human,
it wants to be inside Moose
for totally mysterious reasons,
at least to me. Toxo can only
reproduce sexually in the gut of cat,
so it's there in mooses intestines
that the toxoplasma meet and hook up.
Then they lay eggs.
Next Moose takes a trip to the backyard
where she EGX those eggs in her put.
See what's out there now on the cat
feces. Step two says, suppose key is that,
you know, maybe a week later a rat
will come along and eat the cat poop.
Now toxo has a problem.
It's stuck inside a rat that
really wants to be inside a cat,
but rats totally freak out whenever
they so much as even smell cat.
It's, it's a hardwired aversion and talk.
Sue's evolutionary challenge now has
been to figure out how to get rodents
inside cat stomachs.
Here is where the mind control comes
in and it's kind of hard to believe,
but this is what supposed to be says
happens. Toxo starts off in the stomach.
The welding takes about six weeks to
migrate its way up to the brain and once
it's in there, it finds this
particular region called the Amygdala,
which isn't like command central
for year end design error,
all of that.
It also finds this other region kind of
right next door where a very different
emotion, legs sexual around.
So one way he ran way in what talks so
seems to be able to do is to somehow
cross the wires. This may be some
horrifically simplified sound bite,
but what I think is going on is the
talkshow knows how to make cat urine smell
sexy. What to rodents,
which that is so likable, totally bizarre.
But talk soap makes rodents like the
smell of cats and thus they approach
and they're more likely to wind up
in the cat stomach. That's rough.
Yeah. In all other ways. The
written is totally normal.
Normal olfaction in normal social
behavior. Just hot for cats.
Oh good, good. I start to wonder.
Well, this really likes the microphone.
I love cats. Yeah. Is it possible
that Toxo Lucy is wonderful,
is what's been drawing me to cats.
Sorry, we let her put her for everywhere.
I ask him pure speculation, but people
who think about this stuff with you,
it is not just purely speculative.
The notion that talk so can produce some
sort of attraction to cats and humans.
They don't think that's
all that crazy, Lisa.
So you're saying that like the crazy
cat lady could be toxoplasma? Well,
no one's really studied
that yet. Testing, testing.
But there are scientists out there that
are making the case that talks o can
really change you. Okay.
Probably the most interesting
established link is between Toxo and
schizophrenia.
Are you Dr Tori? Yep. There's
actually been last count,
54 studies on Toxoplasma in people
with schizophrenia and other psychosis.
That's Dr. Fuller Torrey.
He works at the Stanley Medical Research
Institute that sponsors a lot of these
studies. Well,
I've been doing research on schizophrenia
since the early seventies anything?
So there's a link. Yeah,
not a huge effect. Very,
very small risk of schizophrenia simply
because schizophrenia is very rare.
Well, why would it cause
schizophrenia to begin with?
Is it trying to cause schizophrenia?
Is that you imagine if the Toxo
is sort of lost in the brain.
It thinks it's in a rat brain.
Maybe it's just trying to do
what it usually does to rats,
but in humans it has a very
different effect. Nice.
And one of the reasons he
thinks this might be true,
this connection between Toxoplasma and
schizophrenia is because of a historical
link.
The fact that what we now
call schizophrenia was quite
rare until the late part
of the 18th century. And
then during the 18 hundreds,
schizophrenia increased very rapidly. Why?
This was the first time when we
started to keep catches pets.
They first were adopted by the um,
kind of east Greenwich
village types in parish,
the artists. And it was really
considered kind of weird,
but it's the kind of thing that if you
were an artist or writer or something
like that,
you started to do a mini kind of spread
to London now where the writers and
artists kept it there. And then
starting in about the 1840s,
he had started to become
a little bit more popular.
And then in the 1860s and
seventies, it was what called a cat.
Crazy cats were all over bleeding cards.
The first cat show was at London
and 1870 and Madison Square Garden,
I agreed to 80 it became very
fashionable to have a cat,
we should say. I mean he'll agree at
this point it's just a theory. Okay.
But is there any evidence that toxo can
actually control our behavior like it
does with the rats? Well,
there are some scientists out there who
believe that toxo may affect something
more common to all. Okay,
here's another one of those gimme a
break. That's Robert Sapolsky. Again,
science fiction branches to the story.
Two different groups independently have
seen people who are toxo infected have
two to four times the likelihood
of dying in car accidents.
Really? Yeah. And I asked him why,
insofar as toxo makes Rodens get
really imprudent about cat smells,
maybe toxo is making all sorts of
mammals get imprudent about anything that
they're normally a skittish about,
like your body hurdling
through space at a high speed.
So in the end it might be possible,
might be possible that talkshow
is guiding our emotions.
[inaudible]
changing who we are in some basic way.
And if you consider that toxo might
just be one of thousands of tiny little
parasites inside us pulling
our strings from the inside.
Well, that thought is pretty creepy.
Even if the entire lesson with toxo is
a small subset of infected people now
have one half of 1% more likelihood
of wanting to drive really recklessly.
Um,
even lurking in that one half of 1% are
some serious implications for thinking
about freewill.
We haven't a clue the biology lurking in
the background that makes freewill seem
a little bit suspect.
Either way, whatever
happened with your test.
Whoa.
Well this is me with my midwife,
Barry Winter, my absence.
She's giving me the news,
whatever we find out from the Tux.
So test that you have had
past infection with toxoplasma
positive,
you're positive. Yeah, but my midwife
says that the baby's going to be okay.
So the baby look like she's small.
She looks like she's a nice size too.
A little bit on the larger size.
So not a baby I'd be worried
about and I believe her.
Thanks Helen. Sure.